when anthropologists or when
neuroscientists or biologists are
talking
they're not usually talking about the
lives of individual
people they're talking about you know
the species what's better for the
species the survivability of the species
and what's better for the survivability
of the species
is variation that we have lots of
cultures
with lots of different solutions because
if the environment were to change
drastically
um some uh
some of those solutions will work better
than others
and you can see that happening with
covid
right so some people might be more
susceptible to this this virus and
others
and so variation is very useful say kobe
was much much more destructive than it
is
and like i don't know 20 percent of the
population was
died uh you know that's it's good to
have
variability because then at least some
percent will survive
yeah i mean the the you know the way
that i used to describe it was
you know um using uh
you know those movies like the war of
the worlds or um
pacific rim you know where like aliens
come down from outer space
and they you know want to kill humans
and so all the humans band together
as a species like and they all like all
the you know little squabbling
from countries and whatever all you know
goes away and everyone is just
one big you know well
that you know that doesn't happen
i mean because covid is you know the
virus
like co like covered 19 is like
a a creature from outer space and that's
not what you see
happening what you do see happening it
is true that some people
i mean we could use this as an example
of essentialism also so
just to say like exposure to the virus
does not mean that you will become
infected with a disease so
i mean in controlled studies one of
which
was actually a coronavirus not covid but
this was these are studies from tens or
so years ago you know
only somewhere between 20 and 40 percent
of people
were developed respiratory illness when
a virus was placed
in their nose yeah um and so
then there's a dose question all those
well not in these studies actually so in
these studies the dose was
consistent across all people um and
everything you know they were
sequestered in hotel rooms and
what they ate was you know um measured
out by scientists and so on and
so when you hold dos i mean the dose
issue is a real issue in the real world
but
um in these studies that was controlled
um and only somewhere between 20
depending on the study between 20 and 40
percent of people became infected with a
disease
so exposure to a virus doesn't mean
de facto that you will develop an
illness you will be a carrier and you
will
spread the virus to other people but you
yourself may not
uh your immune system may be um in a
state that
um you you can make enough antibodies to
not uh not show symptoms not develop
symptoms
um and so um
of course what this means is again is
that you know
like if i asked you do you think you
know a virus is
the cause of illness of a common cold or
you know most people if i ask this
question i can tell you cause i
i asked this question so do you think a
virus is the cause
of a cold most people would say yes i
think it is
and then i say yeah well only 20 to 40
of people develop
respiratory illness in exposure to a
virus so clearly
it is a necessary cause but it's not a
sufficient cause
and there are other causes again so not
simple single causes for things right
multiple interacting influences
so it is true that individuals vary in
their
susceptibility to illness upon exposure
but different
cultures have different sets of norms
and practices that allow
that will slow or or speed the spread
and that's the that's the point that i
was actually trying to make here that
um that you know when the environment
changes
that is there's a mutation of a virus
that is incredibly infectious
some cultures will succumb
people in some cultures will succumb
faster because of
the particular norms and practices that
that they've developed in their culture
versus other cultures now
there could be some other you know
thing that changes that where
those other other cultures are you know
would do better so
very individualistic cultures like ours
may do
much better under other types of
selection pressures
but for kovid for things like kovid
you know my colleague michelle gelfont
her research shows
that she she looks at like loose
cultures and tight cultures so cultures
that have very very strict
uh rules versus cultures that are much
more individualistic and where personal
freedoms are
more valued and she you know
her research suggests that for pandemic
circumstances tight cultures actually
the people survive better
you